hello everyone this is edward tamisian
i'm the vice president of internet
infidels and i have a paper that was
accepted for publication two years ago
on the origin of evil and theistic card
determinism that anyone can view online
and today for the third time today i'm
going to be interviewing the legendary
bill gatey
and um
he has his own personal website and you
can all check that out i will put a link
to the website on the description part
of the video when this gets distributed
and for our first question today we are
going to be talking about einstein's
train paradox so bill want to tell us a
little bit about this paradox and what
you see are the problems with it
well we got to start with that famous
word time
oh man that word time is a monster the
first thing we have to be aware of is
that in the last 3 000 years
no one has been able to define the word
time
if you look it up uh the first thing
you'll find out there well we don't
really know what it means we don't know
how to define it and then they go on and
use it
and
and
the second problem just as bad maybe
is that they've converted time whatever
that thing is because they couldn't
define it they converted it to a
physical object that's exactly what has
happened they have reified this concept
so what happens whenever they give you a
physical interpretation right
this is uh the official uh special
relativity especially right but general
relativity relativity in general uh
what they do when they
we have two parts we have the
mathematical parts where they put time
the value of time five seconds or
whatever into an equation to describe
something that happened that's on the
one hand
and on the other you have the situation
where they have to give you a physical
interpretation of what that equation
represents
not yet what happens when that happens
that's when they get into trouble
because they say well we're going to
dilate time we're going to travel
through time
and
they stretch time so you ask a simple
question
you say why doesn't the earth fly out of
the solar system
very simple question i mean you would
think any physicist would tell you and
say this is the reason it doesn't fly
out of the solar system
the explanation given by general
relativity in this instance right is
that time is warped
and you say hold it what do you mean
what does that can that possibly mean
what do you mean time is worked
and what they're doing here essentially
they have this this fish snap because
they're going to give you the physical
interpretation now forget about the
equations now right now they're going to
give you the physical interpretations of
what the equation represents at least
there's that's this is their
interpretation of that equation right in
physical terms and what they do they say
look there's this canvas we call space
time
unimaginable space time because it's
four dimensional meaning one of those
dimensions the fourth one is time and
they're going to warp this canvas and
that canvas represents this concept
called space time which somehow
converted into a physical object
and that's how they're going to explain
why the earth or what prevented the
earth from flying out of the solar
system there's this roulette like
mechanism a depression and the earth
rolls around it like uh you know uh like
a little ball around the roulette so the
so we have two issues one the definition
of time
and the other one is that
they casually
convert time
into a physical object they reify the
concept
and then to top it off they say at the
end of their presentation you know they
say oh by the way don't take our
analogies too literally
yeah i don't know
what am i supposed to imagine then yeah
that's a good point what did that all be
what was all that about
oh well yeah false advertisement
this is the starting point okay this is
starting
now now you ask a specific question
about you know time dilation okay yeah
that train paradox video yeah we have
the trained paradox
and i'll give you a quick analogy that
puts everything into the proper focus
okay
these people are saying that when you
and i shake hands
we did not do it at the same time
yeah
that's what it sounds like you had a
different impression than me okay yeah
so for you it happened at two o'clock
for me it happened at three o'clock
that's more or less what they're saying
when we shake hands it didn't happen
simultaneously
that's more or less what we we've got
here they're saying look you've got to
train
okay
and train this i think this was i don't
know who's the first one to come up with
this analogy maybe it was einstein i
don't know but the issue is when you
look at time dilation you got to go back
all the way to lawrence and
juan carre and other people of the 19th
century when albert einstein was still
in his shorts he was a kid at the time
okay these people were already talking
about time dilation uh these notions
that came up really towards the end of
the 19th century right
and uh
continued on to when einstein took over
and got all the credit for it that is a
reality he did not come up with all
these ideas he maybe he perfected them
maybe he put him in nice and neat in a
way that others understood it but he was
not the originator of these ideas that
that has to be set just from the
historical record so what are these
people are saying
what they're saying is is you have a
train
and you have a passenger on the train
okay
and the train is moving towards the
station
and let's assume that it doesn't even
stop at the stage it just continues
rolling so
non-stop trains the express
okay so the train goes
by and you have a
person standing on the platform looking
at the train
that observer let's call him the
stationary observer and you have the
other one moving with the train he's the
moving observer okay now it's a rainy
day we have two lightning bolts
that
simultaneously at the same time hit the
front and back of the train
so
let's assume we we had the uh watch that
god has up there they both hit exactly
at the same time one on the front one on
the back of the train yeah that's what
the the observer sees from far away yeah
okay so and now
that's what the platform guy sees the
guy who's stationary he would see those
bolts strike at the same time
however the passenger
sees something different
he he's moving in the direction of the
uh bolt that hits on the front of the
train
so
as he's moving the light from that event
will hit his eyes faster or sooner than
the
light from the boat that hit the rear of
the train because he's moving away from
it
so if you were to look at the two um
trajectories of light you would see the
one on the front of the train is shorter
and the one on the back and train is
longer
okay
so as far as the uh passenger on the
train he sees the front of the train
being hit before the one on the back
and the platform guy the guy who's
stationary who is more objective in this
situation i guess sees them both hit at
the same time okay so they say look it
all depends on how you measure things
when they're moving
and that's when they have this
relativity that all is relative
yeah what are they all talking about
they're talking about measurements
they're not talking about what actually
happened
under mother nature's world they're
talking about what people measure
yeah so we have a difference between
what actually happened which is what
mother nature knows she's got it in her
file cabinet she knows for sure whether
they hit at the same time or at
different times and then we have the
version of humans which has to do with
measurement that says
one observer will measure one thing the
other guy will measure something else
opinion
okay and that's essentially what we have
here we have a comparison of what
actually happened which we don't know
because we can't reproduce the event
again only mother nature god the devil
one of those guys knows exactly they
have it in their filing cabinet and we
have no access to that filing cabinet
and then you have the human version
which is this is what i measure
and what they're talking about is
essentially measurement of light okay
and they're saying look if we if if we
put light
as a constant 300 000 kilometers per
second rounding off right
if we if if that's a constant
everything else has to change in an
equation in an equation
and so if if we have a difference in
observers
and the speed of light is the same
well then the time for one will be
different than time for the other
because we do have that constant which
we can't change which is the speed of
light
and that also has uh a sequel which is
that people are saying well the speed of
light is not constant a lot of people
say that right it's not a constant and
einstein proved it but he could be wrong
and you know they go through all these
arguments
but the point is that officially the
speed of light is a constant travels at
a constant speed and when you put that
into the equation you will see that what
changes are the length of an object the
mass of an object and the time that it
took to
to carry to cover a certain distance so
that's a situation with uh with time
dilation
yeah awesome yeah and uh like you were
saying you know
and like i was thinking as well like
either the lightning hit both sides
simultaneously or it identity you can't
say it didn't it didn't you know that's
a contradiction like you know so you
proposed i think in your you stupid
relatives website you had a page where
you concocted an experiment and you were
like so a perfect machine is inside of
the train and if it detect and we strap
einstein and put something over his
mouth and put him in a chair and if the
machine detects lightning hitting both
sides simultaneously einstein gets
zapped but if it detects lightning
hitting one side before the other then
he lives like and like you know
obviously it's either the machine you
know isn't based upon perception or you
know it's not going to go off of you
know trajectory of light hitting it
first like it's going to measure things
objectively like either it's going to
detect both sides being hit
simultaneously or it won't so like
that's the way you solve the paradox and
show like both observers can't be
correct because that's a contradiction
to say hit both sides and then didn't
hit both sides like that's just not how
things happen like either a ditto or a
dinner so that was a good little thought
experiment you could concoct you know
putting that machine like in the uh
train and then yeah so and then you know
uh bill goes into more detail on um his
website like i said i'll post a link to
that so that was an interesting uh
thought experiment there
and um
there's a follow-up on that thought
experiment related doesn't have to do
specifically with that but it has to do
with time dilation again the issue of
simultaneity right and that's the famous
twin paradox
okay
and in this case you've got one one
this again a thought experiment they say
look one of the travelers uh one of the
twins i'm sorry travels out of the earth
goes around the black hole goes around
the universe comes back and he finds
that his brother
has aged his brother looks like a
grandfather and the guy who traveled
still looks like a kid or a young guy
so this guy has 40 more years on him
this guy is still 20 years old
that's more or less the idea and and
again
it's because they do math
and they forget about physics again
mathematical physics has nothing to do
with physics and you can see because
they arrive at irrational conclusions
and the way i solve this one more or
less along the lines of of good aligning
being sat uh you know in this chair and
being zapped by you know by electricity
here we have a similar situation and and
this is the way i try to you know attack
this notion that one traveler would stay
young the traveler would stay young and
his twin brother would age and i'm
saying we've got a problem and the
problem is as follows
how do we count
years i mean we're going to talk about
this guy's 40 years older than this guy
in time timewise right but by the clock
how how do we determine the year
if you look up the word year
right the definition it's one uh
circle of the earth around the sun
now i don't care how many years this guy
traveled i don't care how many
what each one has in his head
i need to know objectively how many
times the earth went around the sun
now it either went around the sun 20
times or 60 times right we can't have it
both ways and so if this guy travels
outside the universe if you want you can
travel to heaven and back for all i care
when he comes back
the number of times the earth went
around the sun has to be either 20 or
60. it can't be both
yeah
and so he can't say well this guy for
this guy uh the earth uh had 60 years
but for me it only had 20 years now this
is very simple we just have to count how
many times the earth went around the sun
and one of the two is wrong
yeah that that's true
yeah yeah yep that's a good way to do it
all righty well thanks a lot for that
input and then for our final question
for today uh if everyone didn't know in
our last interview we talked about bill
gates uh previous life as a cuban spy
and how he eventually moved to united
states and ended up working with a
counter espionage mission with the fbi
and cia to obtain uh data from intel
and he talked about the history of that
and this has been featured on fox news
uh bill gatey has a segment on his
website that featured uh you know when
this ordeal was happening and stuff like
that and his responses and everything
and uh today we're gonna finish up and
talk about an individual by the name of
captain jose pepe and so uh what
affiliation do you have with uh or did
have with captain jose pepin how does it
relate to your spy life
uh his his name is jose cohen valdez
okay
jose everyone who's called jose in
spanish uh we call him pepe
okay all right that's how that works so
okay gotcha gotcha all right it goes by
pepe cohen or jose cohen anyways uh uh
my wife and i went to cuba we were
invited by the cuban government by fidel
castro through its ministry of interior
and i told you the other day how i got
there all the way through canada and
said oh yeah yeah
people will simply have to look at your
previous video there
anyway i won't go over that again but uh
the point is we got to meet uh pepe as
we call them even to this day we know
him as pepe and uh what happened was you
know i had my controller in mexico city
and his name was um julian rosa that was
his alias his real name was orlando
betancourt and we found out about that
through pepe when we went on the island
but it turns out when we arrived at the
marti airport uh orlando and others uh
julian rosa my controller he was there
to meet us because now we had a new
controller in mexico okay we have a new
handler and so he since he knew us he's
the guy who received at the at the foot
of the airplane and the first person he
introduced to us was pepe cohen okay
this is one of our finest and uh
pepe was a fanatic communist at up to
that moment okay
and he was designated as
our chaperone around the island so they
took us to uh pinard on the western side
of the uh of cuba where they have the
combinado where they made the chips over
there okay where all the information was
going to that part of the island to the
western side of the island and it took
us also to other parts of cuba okay
not to guantanamo
the point is that throughout the two
weeks that we were with him that he took
us around the island
we had a lot of discussions
and i mean the discussion there were
debates and discussions
and partly he he was fanatic uh a
fanatic follower of fidel castro and he
defended the revolution he defended
fidel castro and
i couldn't bad mouth the revolution too
much right but at the same time i
thought i'd point out some of the
deficiencies and so i would
do sometimes i would do it through jokes
you know like saying uh
uh you know um
we were walking down the street and
paper would say something like did you
notice that the streets are clean there
are no candy wrappers or anything like
that on the streets
and i would give them a little punch in
the nose and say
well really in a country that has no
candies there can't be any candy
wrappers
you know so i would throw some some low
blows okay
and and he picked them he picked up on
them and but he was trying to convince
me that the revolution was on the right
track and everything and so on well the
point is after two weeks i think he got
the idea that we were not too enthused
with a revolution that there were lots
of problems in cuba and uh one of those
big problems was that when they toured
us
they they took us to model everything
model schools model constructions model
factories uh everything was modeled it
was not the ordinary middle of the road
it was just the best that cuba had to
offer
and even so it was in in pretty bad
shape
now you know we didn't expect nothing
out of the ordinary from cuba because
again everybody thinks of cuba as a
banana republic in fact it's shaped like
a banana
okay and so you think of it as a banana
republic you cannot expect for it to be
you know like germany or some other
advanced nation
but at the same time there were many
problems that were due to inefficiency
that's that's the issue and so well what
happened was we pointed these things out
even though we were treated like royalty
and
you know and when we left i think he
wrote a report to fidel castro i'm sure
they requested a report from him uh
ministry of interior and i don't think
he treated i mean i don't know what the
report said to this day but i'm sure
that he didn't treat us
very well in the sense that saying oh
these are gung-ho people these are great
people you know i think he he probably
told the truth and said look you know
these people have are losing heart with
a revolution you know etcetera etcetera
i think that's what we he his report
so the second time when we went to cuba
okay we went again
a couple years later
and at that time i think they were
prepared for us you know they weren't
prepared in the sense that they didn't
know we were coming we just showed up
but we the first thing i did was make
contact with the
interior ministry and they immediately
put baby in charge of chaperoning us
again
but by this time you know things have
changed you know and
they started working to
turn us around to your turn us into a
different type of egypt
they really wanted us to infiltrate the
cia without us knowing without us being
aware
okay
so they used pepe who was our friend to
convince us that he had changed his mind
about the revolution that he was no
longer
a uh
a revolutionary that thanks to the
chance that he had with me he changed
his mind et cetera et cetera okay and so
he he approaches us and he talks to us
at the riviera hotel
now we were at the saint john's a lousy
10th uh you know no star hotel
some star hotel it's a no star hotel uh
it had no running no hot water for
example
so they moved us you know the cuban
government says no we're not going to
let you stay there we're going to move
you to the riviera
and we say well don't bother it's okay
you know and they moved us anyways they
moved us to the riviera and that's when
pepe came one day and said confess to us
i've changed my mind i want to overthrow
this i want to overthrow fidel castro
blah blah blah
and we started uh having this uh
subversive reunions we had several of
those okay
and what happened was
we uh we went back to the states
and what they wanted us to do is to um
begin planning on getting him out of the
island
so when i went back to the states i i
tried to prepare a couple passports to
get him and his wife and the kids you
know his kid he had three kids get them
all five of them out of the country
we went back
this was in january of 92 we went back
in june of 92 again but this time we
told him in advance we told our
hamburger in mexico that we were going
to cuba we went into cuba this time
through mexico
and when we get there
uh
pepe introduces us
to a new member of the group which he
called pier pr2
partido revolucionario number two number
one was a rt i was a revolutionary party
number two pr2 so now we were pr to my
wife me
pepe and the guy he introduces to us
which is rolando saraf trujillo
we called him rolly okay
he introduced roy to us as a friend from
high school he said we did high school
together and we finally decided to
found the courage to confess to each
other that we both hated the revolution
he works also in the ministry of
interior he worked in the
m15 which was the group that did uh
spying on the spies
spying on their own people so if someone
was out of line they would tell fidel
castro look this guy i think he lost his
revolutionary fervor
they were tattletails essentially okay
and and that's where rowley worked
because he studied journalism
okay
so what happens they the two of them
inside us and tell us to go to the cia
they give us information which they
allegedly
pulled out of the ministry of interior
they gave it to us
we come back to the states
and my wife wanted to kill me but
i went to the cia and i turned myself in
that's essentially what happened yeah
and then you told me about that in your
last interview okay and so i confess to
them and then uh 45 days later the fbi
appears at my house in austin texas and
from there we begin on a two-year
relationship with the agencies
and what happened was that you know just
to make a long story short
uh the the fbi convinced me that
these people were not for real that
fidel castro was behind them
even though they turned over some very
important information according to the
fbi
they still didn't believe them and they
were not about to send someone over to
cuba someone from the cia or some
intelligence agency to get them out
because they didn't know if it was a
setup and fidel castro would get that
guy and put him you know on tv for the
world to see love what the americans are
doing blah blah blah you know
so they weren't going to risk it because
they said we don't believe these people
we don't think they're for real we think
fidel is behind this whole thing and so
they never
really risked anything and meanwhile
they kept sending information through me
to the fbi
okay
and so while we have these things
there's a lot more going on but the
point here is the following uh a few
years later in 1994
uh pepe leaves the island
on a raft he gets out of there the
fbi the cia no one ever went after him
he had to leave on his own he left on a
raft okay he leaves and arrives in miami
today he's an amway salesman who's doing
quite well okay that's nice he did he's
a used car salesman very fast talker he
can miss a lot of people more important
is the guy that in 2015 was let go was
uh
exchanged by obama
obama exchanged three prisoners at the
head of the cubans who were serving some
time in american prisons and which the
cubans wanted back
they changed these they exchanged these
three fellows who were in in american
prisons for two people
one of them
was uh
alan groves
who had been um
taken over there or had been arrested on
charges of doing something with
um
internet uh some communication stuff
the other fellow was rolando
mr rooney
my good old buddy
and he had been in prison for 20 years
what happened here what really happened
here was obama went to cuba or they
discussed with raul castro right the new
president because fidel had retired by
then
had discussed with raul castro
look we can give you these three guys
and maybe we can open up relations
between cuba and united states what's
standing in the way is that you guys got
this guy alan gross and we got these
three cubans which you want and we need
to reach some kind of agreement and so
they said well if you give us alan gross
he's not really a spy and if you do give
us him as a spy people will say ah he
was a spy wasn't he and so we don't want
that
and so they pitched in they said who can
we pitch in
and they thought about quality he was a
perfect candidate he was a perfect
candidate because no one knew anything
about him
the
interior ministry had been revamped
completely after pepe left the island
because he had too much information so
they had to redo everything
and uh it turns out that when pepe left
they uh they immediately
recalled um
roli from russia he was in moscow he was
uh some kind of attache
in the cuban embassy in moscow they
recalled him when he arrived at martin
they arrested him
they tried him
and in that trial
hip his wife was kind of compelled
forced to
uh testify against him that he was part
of a cell and blah blah blah a bunch of
lies because the cuban government knew
he was in a cell because the cell was
prepared by fidel
so they had about they had the grids on
him but they turned back
around they stabbed him in the back why
because
they realized that roely was about to
defect as well from russia
and so they said
come over here uh we got a
we got a raise for you
we're going to promote
and they promoted him to prison and he
spent 20 years in prison
and they they gave him 25 years but he
served 20 years most of that time in
solitaire by the way
and it turns out they didn't let him go
and they would have executed him if it
weren't because his parents were were
from the cuban revolution 1959 they were
supporters of that revolution they were
part of the army etc and
as a reference to them they said look
we're going to put them in prison and
they left them in prison for 20 years no
one knew anything about rowley here in
the states right nobody uh
knew anything anyways about the interior
ministry because it was revamped
completely refurbished right changed
completely
and so here they said look we can invent
any story about this guy because nobody
knows anything about him
and so they invented the story that he
gave the codes to the united states to
catch uh you know uh spies in the united
states americans that were spying
against the us government in favor of
cuba and then and so they use that they
say oh it was really
that he gave us the codes and that's why
they arrested him right okay and it
turns out that really had nothing to do
with codes he knew nothing about
cryptography he was a journalist uh
fidel castro was not that desperate that
he used journalists to do cryptography
that's done by mathematicians okay
pepe's wife
was a mathematician she was in the
cryptography department two different
ones at different times and uh
and you know they didn't arrest her they
let her go but they arrested meroli and
locked them up so here they uh let roly
go okay he comes to the united states
the three cubans that went to
cuba to see roller coaster they were put
on tv heroes blah blah blah alan gross
came here he to the states he was
treated as a hero also the the
u.s flag behind him he talked to the
press everything
really he was whisked in secret no one
that was able to interview him or even
talk to him
they said they had to debrief him
debrief for what i mean after 20 years
in prison he's got nothing to be
debriefed about yeah that's true
if you look up rolando
that's his name right if you look him up
you won't find any information in the
last
20 years
you won't find any kind of information
in the last 20 years on him
well that's how it happens sometimes
unfortunately
yeah you won't find any information on
him because for um
for
the last seven years
no one has interviewed him no one knows
anything about the thing just
the
journals the journalists the
news agencies they all dropped the ball
on it no one followed up and said well
who was this guy that uh obama released
you know nobody knows anything about him
to this day nobody cares he just died by
pocket veto
oh man
but if you want to know the story of
rolando
you came to the right guy the guy was
exchanged by obama you got to go to my
site i've written five articles on that
okay big articles that you can see you
see the whole story of him and pepe
in there what actually happened from my
point of view okay
and what you're going to see there you
go to you stupid relativist.com
you
stupidrelativist.com if you go there you
look for rolando
you'll see it on the lower left in the
english section
and there you can read all about him and
i've got some videos on him as well like
five videos or whatever and uh you'll
see the whole story there if you really
wanna interested in what happened to
these two fellows uh jose cohen and uh
fantastic story arc i think it actually
spanned in all three interviews because
i think even in the first one we kind of
talked about your spy life and how you
were you know turned over by the cia and
stuff
but um so um captain jose pepe it was
the most high-ranking person that worked
under fidel castro that you met
no no no he he was not he was only a
lieutenant in fact but sometimes those
people are more valuable like the fbi
told me they're more valuable because
they're in the day-to-day things they
knew the little details see when you get
one of these generals when you get a
kernel someone up there they have the
general picture and they might have
something for obviously they they would
have information that the cia would be
interested in because they have this big
picture view of things but then when you
get a lieutenant someone at the lower
level
not only does he know the buddies that
work with him the names etc and he knows
him you know
he knows their real names right where
they live how many kids they have
he knows all the details right but he
also knows the day-to-day operations of
what's going on inside the offices
you know and what they do and how they
do it the procedures they have a lot of
information that is very useful and the
cia did try to get
or or was planning on or was intent on
getting both uh
pepe uh rolly and pippi's wife out of
there they were trying to get them out
but they wouldn't risk it under the eyes
of fidel castro and they're right
gotcha yeah so who who was the person
who had like the most authority under
fidel that you met in person
because i know you never met him but
yeah i met several person i met the
minister of electronics his name was
rojas
i met
the head of the m6r group in the
ministry of um
of the interior uh we we worked for the
um
my my cell was the m6 the m6 was charged
with eluding the american embargo
especially on technological stuff that's
why i ended up with them and the head of
that was uh colonel uh broche
his name was
yeah and he went by the name of uh marco
that was his his alias uh his name was
agustin
he was a colonel at the time probably
ascended to general at some point and he
was a big man he a very intelligent foul
by the way you know fidel chooses his
people very carefully
yeah so you know i met a lot of these
people i met renee uh that was also his
um
his uh nom de guerre uh his uh true name
was only obvides
escaped cuba
quotations
very much quotations because it turns
out that um one of the reasons we turned
ourselves in for the second time we
escaped from the fbi the cia uh we were
eight months on the road they couldn't
find us and finally because of things
that happened we decided to turn
ourselves in for the second time to the
fbi gave him a call
whereabouts and the reason we did was
ornelio beovides had escaped the island
now that was so tricky that it was very
hard to believe for the fbi you we we
bought it because we were very naive
with my wife right about these things
but the fbi convinced us that that
doesn't happen what had happened was
that this was the story they they told
us pepe told them told us this from cuba
he said look someone overheard
or nearly
overheard him say something
anti-revolutionary
and so
they they took him out of his job and he
was pippa's boss
okay
between
he was a major in the army and he was
over pepe and so they uh they put him
aside
until they did their investigation
listen to the story this is what they
told us that they put him aside they
took him out of there you know for
security reasons and they were
investigating him
but
they put him to work at the marti
airport
already very suspicious like you know a
baggage handler or whatever he was doing
but what was he doing in the marti
airport you would think they would put
them in the fields cutting cane
right
or maybe keep them out of a job for a
while until they investigate now the
story goes he was put to work at the
marti airport
while at the marti airport he fabricated
a passport a fake passport
this is the story they told us he
fabricated a fake passport got on an
aeroflot uh iroflot
flight out of cuba without knowing
knowing apparently because he had a
different name in his passport he lands
in ireland
the flight continued to moscow but he
turns himself to the authorities in
ireland who called the cia who came and
picked them up who took him to
washington dc
and while he was in washington dc being
drilled over there we were being drilled
in austin texas by the fbi and the cia
so that was the story
dance the jig in ireland
the beer yeah i mean like sounds a
little too uh
yeah contrived like sounds a little too
uh elaborated to be something that
actually happened oh well well yeah
what did happen what did happen what was
the reality of that was that yes he did
escape cuba he did land in ireland he
was picked up by the cia brought to the
united states to washington d.c that
part happened because they confirmed
look we've got
uh on you in other words uh renee we've
got him over there in washington and
they were asking him questions putting
him through lie detectors maybe
waterboarding him i don't know
i was never born
dang
and they were questioning us and uh put
us through lie detectors in uh in austin
texas and they were doing the same thing
to him over there they wouldn't have the
light detector on you
i'm sorry they used the light detector
on youtube several times
seven or eight lie detectors taking on
me but this is the issue the issue is
they were questioning him they were
questioning me and so the issue was why
of all people in cuba
a guy who knew me
whom i knew him
it turns out that this is the guy that
happens to escape out of cuba
for saying something
anti-revolutionary for being put to work
at the airport where he fabricated a
passport and without anybody knowing he
gets on an aeroflot plane and flies out
of cuba that part was uh you know for
hollywood
the fbi had very hard time believing
that all that happened on the island the
other part is true he did land in
ireland he landed in dublin and from
there he was picked up and brought to
the states
awesome all righty well thank you for uh
concluding that story
alrighty and then uh before we close out
do you have any i know you do uh do you
still do lectures like around other
countries and stuff or do you just do
them at your house because i know
sometimes you were like at some maybe
like some conferences or whatever or you
made like a powerpoint slide about your
like your views on physics and stuff do
you still do that
yeah we uh we've had um a conference
almost every year we suspended because
of the covid so we've been
okay that's right
and uh but i think we might start again
uh there's one offer to do the next one
maybe in mexico
uh so we got to see how these things
work out that's just one possibility uh
there are others we're exploring and we
might get together we have a staunch
group of people who
are interested in the theory and who
want to explore it and develop it
further and
people have written books on it so uh
we'll see maybe we get together in some
country again and um
and continue on with the rope model of
light and gravity awesome yeah i'm glad
some other people are picking up on it
that is awesome
alrighty well thanks again for another
fantastic interview and in a couple of
minutes i will have this posted on my uh
freethinker podcast and then you can you
know distribute it on your site and then
you know share it on your your facebook
page do whatever you like with it
okay we'll see you brady thank you have
a good day